AUDIENCE MEMBER: I was wondering if
either of you, whether you could compare the
French attitude towards Muslim immigrants
with the attitude in the US? Because it seems like US
distrust
of Muslim communities here is fueled more
by fears of terrorism than anything, in that
the religious aspects are more a side
effect of, like-- it's not a direct assault
on, like, the veil or something like that.
And so I was wondering why that might be. Is it
because
the US is generally a more religious country
and so is less inclined to distrust religious practices
just because they are religious practices?
Or is there a certain different organization of
Muslim communities here that makes them
more willing to integrate, I suppose, into
American communal life?
GORSKI: I mean I think,
you know, Ates
kind of outlined the
usual and also, I think, correct answer
to that question, which is,
it has to do with the very different political
histories, and therefore very different political
cultures,
of France and the United States. In
particular, that
the dominance, the predominance,
of particular-- what I would call radical or
secularist republicanism,
you know, with its origins in the French
Revolution.
THe US also has been
deeply influenced by republicanism, but
it was a different kind of republicanism--
a more deistic republicanism which never
took the kind of radically
anti-clericalist bent
that the French Revolution did, and
there has always-- there--
it--
there is, you know, certainly from kind of
the early republic on, increasingly
a kind of laissez-faire liberalism
which emerges, which
basically understands religion as a form
of self--
as a-- as, you know, a right,
sort of falling into the rights of conscience,
and as a form of self-expression.
And that's been reinforced historically, of course,
through the arrival and absorption-- and
emergence of more and more-- more and more
religious groups.
To answer the other question, though, about--
and I don't know, maybe Ates is going
to disagree with me about this-- I don't think
that you can pull apart the headscarf
debate and--
and 9/11 and other-- other
encounters like that. So, for example, one
of my students last year wrote a thesis
on British and French discourse around
the headscarf debate, and
there is a
remarkable shift
within Britain, after
9/11,
away from multiculturalism and towards something,
actually, that increasingly looks like
French republicanism, and a similar
shift can be seen
in the Netherlands. So there, the kind
of-- the catalyst for that is the Theo Van Gogh
murder.
But, you know, a similar kind of backlash.